welcome back to the show Luke Beasley
filling in for David while he is away if
you want to check me out you like what
you see Luke Beasley on YouTube the link
should be in the description if you're
watching on YouTube radical republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
appeared on Fox news with Sean Hannity
kind of continuing in her tour of trying
to make herself more mainstream let's
forget all the past Bonkers conspiracy
theorists things I've said and make me a
serious congresswoman and conservative
media is assisting in that in the
Republican party is assisting in that
well
especially the third clip I'm going to
show you out of this interview really
highlights how little both Sean Hannity
and Marjorie green understand about what
they're talking about and it's honestly
really embarrassing
um for these two individuals but before
we do that the first two clips relate to
the removing of certain Democratic
Congress people from committee so I'll
show you these and then we'll get to the
really Bonkers clip
no not at all and you can see there's a
major difference in the leadership with
Kevin McCarthy as Speaker of the House
and Nancy Pelosi is Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi and the Democrats removed
me from committees from things they
didn't like on my Facebook years before
I became a member of Congress but you
can see that Kevin McCarthy isn't being
political he's removing members of
Congress that need to be removed it's a
so she's correct that
Nancy Pelosi and Kevin McCarthy are very
different in the type of speaker they're
going to be but not in the way uh that
she would believe necessarily and
I'll show you the next clip actually and
then we'll discuss about this
committee's issue is Kevin McCarthy a
speaker of the house is doing the right
thing and removing these Democrat
members that deserve to be removed ilhan
Omar is another example she's
anti-semitic and she should not be on
Foreign Affairs these aren't political
things these are the right things to do
so
from the Jewish space lasers believing
person she's saying that Illinois is
anti-Semitic and that's why she
shouldn't be on committees
but to the point of
Kev McCarthy is not doing these actions
for political purposes but instead for
good reason is completely silly because
I don't think there's any better reason
to remove someone from committees than
the reasons Democrats did Paul gosar
posting that animation of AOC getting
killed and then Marjorie Greene and all
for conspiracy theories the Jewish space
lasers and all of that those are good
reasons that someone probably shouldn't
be serving on committees it's absolutely
a hundred percent political that Kev
McCarthy is taking people off of
committees that are perfectly qualified
to serve in those positions but are
Democrats and uh that's the real reason
okay so third clip watch them discuss
and watch how Sean Hannity sets up the
conversation around the debt ceiling and
How Deeply confused he gets and then
Marjorie green just goes along with the
confusion let me ask you
um I know the Democrats desperately want
to distract from the the issue of the
president and the classified top secret
documents now in four locations I get
that so they're trying to Gin up the
American people on the issue of the debt
ceiling my understanding is that really
won't be an issue for a number of months
but when it is an issue what will
Republicans do will they be United what
are the things that they will demand
in exchange for going along with the
debt ceiling because the hyperbole I'm
sure will be out of control of Full
Faith and and gov of the United States
government is on the line and credit of
the government is on the line uh you're
going to shut down the government and
meanwhile people will still get their
Social Security checks their Medicare
the military will be up and running and
most people get a furlough and they get
paid when they get back to work so all
that hyperbole is coming but what will
the Republicans want and will they stay
together
okay so we will let Marjorie green
answer but first let's just kind of
break down what was so confused about
that setup to the question what did he
do there he merged the concepts of
funding the government and raising the
debt ceiling now these things will
coincide and the negotiations might get
intertwined and be going on at similar
times and but the
the funding of the government and the
government shutdowns that are threatened
is different than the raising of the
debt ceiling and us falling through on
our financial obligations so he's
correct that whenever we get in the
negotiations about funding the
government if they don't come to an
agreement within the government and the
government shuts down
the necessary functions of the
government still move forward but if it
goes on long enough negative
consequences absolutely occur but then
he shifted and kind of blended into the
Full Faith and Credit in the United
States and the fact that we would be in
a bad economic situation and we would be
losing worldwide credibility if we
didn't raise a debt ceiling and follow
through on our financial obligations and
blending those two things in his setup
to make it seem like it's not a big deal
and they're gonna fear Monger so
whenever you hear it don't take it
seriously but we should take seriously
both of those things but not right in
the debt ceiling could be disastrous and
it's not the time to argue overspending
if you don't want the government to
spend as much you have to push for that
when you're deciding on spending that
makes a whole lot of sense which would
be when you're passing bills when you're
debating over the funding of different
programs but when you talk about raising
the debt ceiling that's just following
through on financial obligation spending
that's already been committed to
and we must do that to stay credible
as
um a government with that and all of
those things and so he's completely
discombobulated setting up that question
but here's her answer
well I think this is an important issue
to talk about Sean thank you for
bringing it up but we also want to point
out that Nancy Pelosi Chuck Schumer Joe
Biden Mitch McConnell all of who have
served if you add up the years they've
been in Congress or are in power in
Washington we're looking at 150 years of
four people's combined uh time in
Washington so they know what they're
doing when they kick the can down the
road giving the debt ceiling issue to
the Republican majority which we started
here in January it's an important issue
for our conference to come together on
because as you said the government will
keep on running yes people's social and
again she's merging the concepts but we
will skip forward to a pretty notable
part here at the end you have to have I
for one will not sign a clean bill
raising the debt the debt limit
so she won't
buy into a clean bill raising the debt
ceiling
there it is and I've talked about
extensively now on my show that this is
the Republican nonsense we saw
foreshadowed with the Kev McCarthy
speakership debacle and we're going to
be experiencing this I know David has
also talked a ton about this we will be
experiencing this for the next two years
and it will be a disaster after disaster
and debacle after debacle
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives a significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman 1 use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below